[Music]
[Applause]
did anybody say that
[Music]
yeah the irrational fear of Charisma
charm and Excellence is fat phobia
t-h-a-t but
an even more pervasive phobia in our
country is fat phobia f-a-t phobia which
is the irrational fear of obesity I
guess I'm gonna learn what it is today
in this fat phobia Tick Tock lesson this
is brought To Us by Jen you sell when
you want to look good make sure you
check out gen yourself more from them in
a moment for now though let the lesson
begin I'm gonna be really honest there's
a lot of really fat phobic people out
there
even in the queer Community shut up I
was a go-go dancer at a pride party and
the amount of money that I made versus
the amount of money that the thin people
made was not the same sometimes people
don't even feel comfortable like putting
the money in my underwear but people are
like really awkward with like should I
touch you should I and I see them fully
touching other people
so those are little reminders that
people still have a lot of work to do
around their fat phobia
[Music]
usually there's a silver lining usually
they say like oh well you're seeking
something but it's gone a little bit
here
like everything she said is wrong tell
us how you really feel you know what
I'll tell you how I really feel listen
she should not be stripping she should
not be don't be a go-go dancer don't
exalt unhealthy behaviors and Lifestyles
don't exalt a perverse and disordered
view of human sexuality just what
too right like it's not as though this
woman is just flourishing and so
brimming with joy so things aren't
working out and and so as a good rule of
thumb if I were this woman or if I were
someone looking to this woman for advice
I would say whatever you are doing
just do the opposite I'm so glad that
someone posted this because this shows
you that bones are literally different
you see what's going on big bones
uh never mind that's actually a gorilla
on the right side sorry I'm just gonna
say I'm pretty sure that's a giant ape
wait a second not big wound I'm just fat
yeah big bound isn't real that's not a
real situation yeah people have
different metabolism at the very least
yeah that's true people have different
body chemistry but if you're out of
shape
you can't you can't blame it on your
bones you're out of shape because it's
your that's your body it's your meat and
your muscles and your fat and there's no
there's no excuse right now go to
genucel.com knowlesyt as you might know
we are all big fans of genocell over
here but you don't just need to take my
word for how great a company it is Ella
from Rockford says quote I have both age
and acne spots and this stuff is
actually fading both of them this Serum
is worth every penny Ella is raving
about the famous Dark Spot Corrector
from genucel a must-have after months of
record heat and humidity sunspots brown
spots discoloration even red inflamed
patches all disappear in front of your
very eyes here's the genucel amazing
guarantee you will see results on day
one or your money back so take advantage
of geniusell's most popular package
which now includes the Dark Spot
Corrector plus the classic geniusell
bags and puffiness treatment and
immediate effects all at about 70 70 off
so you can try the best skincare in the
world for yourself completely risk-free
it is simple go to Jenny cell.com
knowlesyt letter y letter T start
looking years even decades younger
tomorrow say goodbye to dark and liver
spots bags and puffiness under the eyes
crow's feet at genucel.com knowlesyt
that is genucel.com
Knowles YT give me more fat phobia I
don't know fashion makes like no money
unless you're a thin white woman
so
being plus size in the social media
industry is definitely been hard there's
visibly fat plus size people and then
there's people with the quintessential
perfect curves like almost unfortunately
how plus size are you okay so I am a
plus size supermodel so everything I do
is pretty much lifestyle around that I
have a lot I will put you first I'd like
to yeah you have so many strings of
income
foreign
[Music]
first of all she makes enough money
would she make 120 Grand a year as a
pretty good money but but if that
depresses her or something then she
could just do something else seems like
she's setting herself up for failure
there next one and this is like maybe a
controversial take but I don't think
that the majority of fat people until
you learn about body Liberation and body
positivity no one would choose to
continue to be fat in a world where they
absolutely hate fat people people think
that I'm glorifying obesity by spreading
this the word and like telling everybody
about this information I trust me I
wouldn't recommend anybody be fat in
this world it is horrible it is so
traumatizing it is so isolating people
are evil they are cruel Strangers think
it's okay to tell you on the bus you're
fat you should lose weight you're just
dusting like it's Non-Stop and that
leads to people isolating themselves and
like seeking Comfort through food I like
this argument this seems to be the most
honest argument of all the fact phobia
you know sympathy seeking groups out
there which is yeah no one would choose
this oh I'm an overweight middle-aged
man and that's usually the line that's
associated with gay guys at least it was
in the 90s now we're told everyone would
choose it and it's wonderful and you
know it's a positive but in the 90s
people would say look no one would
choose to be gay no one would choose to
be attracted to the same sex so that's
why we've got to be accepting of all of
these things and I think that's probably
fair enough when you're being gluttonous
when your body is out of proportion when
you're when all of your desires are out
of proportion it's true nobody would
choose that and so what some people try
to do is just cope and and as a defense
mechanism say no it's actually a good
thing it's wonderful there's nothing
disorder there's nothing wrong here but
deep down they know it's it's
unfortunate and then people can be cruel
and then they see Comfort through food
that's all all true I eat because I'm
unhappy and I'm unhappy because I eat so
yeah nobody would
choose those kinds of inclinations but
it's nevertheless incumbent on people to
work on them you should be encouraged to
just keep trying to improve your
situation and Tamp down on the vice and
practice virtue and then you'd be
happier I hope this lesson has been
educational for you and you will cut it
out with all of that fat phobia fat and
start pursuing
fat philia p-h-a-t
p-h-i-l-i-a
think about that
come on get happy
[Music]